I love taking photos I have so many
memories stored on my phone look at this
photo I took last week with my dog it's
my favorite photo I've ever taken and
these from our walks
I am so glad I have Google photos it
makes it so easy to store organize and
share my pictures I can access my photos
from anywhere and then share them with
anybody I choose across the world and it
doesn't just do it for you and me it
stores photos and memories for over 1
billion users at that scale it must be
an engineering challenge and a Marvel to
uncover and learn about are you excited
to take a dive if it's me and how Google
photos Works stick around because this
is going to be fun
[Music]
thank you
hi everyone I'm Priyanka vergarya and
today I'm here with Tracy and Dave from
our Google photos team who will help us
take a closer look at how Google photos
Works hi Tracy and Dave hey Priyanka hey
Priyanka great to be here today
so I'm Dave I'm a senior software
engineering manager at Google and I lead
the storage serving and ml
infrastructure teams for Google photos
and I'm Tracy a senior site reliability
manager with Google photos and I've led
the photos SRE team for over the past
three years my team and Dave's team work
very closely to ensure that photos is
reliable available and efficient and
that's no small task given that photos
serves over a billion users as you said
Priyanka and we continue to grow
that's right Google photos is such a
huge application and if we really I just
want to dive deeper into how it works
I'm so curious so if we track let's say
life of a photo uh I took a picture on
my phone what is actually happening
behind the scenes can you walk us
through that Dave
we have a lot of cool stuff going on in
our system so it all starts when a user
captures a photo or video on their phone
Google photos will begin to upload the
photos and videos to our product if that
user has the backup feature enabled
backup is a really important feature
it's very popular and it helps users
automatically preserve their memories
backup actually happens in two phases so
first we upload all of the captured
media bytes into our encrypted blob
store and then we upload encrypt and
store all of the associated metadata in
spanner things like exif data file name
and other product metadata at that point
the user's photos and videos are safely
stored in Google photos and we know that
users trust us with their data so we
take a lot of care a lot of time a lot
of energy to make sure that the core
values of privacy and security are kept
in mind but honestly uploading the media
is just step one from there a whole
bunch of asynchronous processing kicks
off much of which is tailored to a
user's individual settings that
processing drives many of Google photos
most magical machine learning powered
features like Memories search and a
bunch of organizational features and
users get to experience these features
just very shortly after upload you just
described it so well there because you
upload the pictures and that upload part
is sort of not even like I'm not even a
part of it I just took a picture it
automatically backs up it automatically
goes there and then if I'm even not
doing anything I just go back after a
few days and I see some memories so it's
just this that seamless processing of
things that is happening behind the
scenes as a user it is magical as an
experience so thanks for walking us
through that so Tracy how as we are as
users are able to access these photos
all the time really reliably across the
globe what happens there
hey Priyanka great question as you said
that's the magical part of photos and
photo actually relies on spanner to
automatically replicate our data and
ensure that the data is co-located with
our Global user footprints the sharding
by spanner also gives us low latency
worldwide and makes it easy for us to
support the ever increasing set of
regulatory requirements concerning data
residency
however as the SRE in the room what's
really interesting to us is that the
system simultaneously has to be reliable
and available for our user uploads what
you experience but we also need to
ensure that our ml-based features that
Dave talked about also perform well
and that ML and batch features and
Computing can't impact our interactive
users so Spanish sharding flexibility
allows us both use cases to be satisfied
in the same database we have read only
and write shards to separate these use
cases because we need to serve our
active online users quickly because we
know they expect their photos to be
instantaneously displayed and shareable
and we don't want those ML and batch
features which are bringing a lot of the
magic to photos to interrupt them we
don't want to slow our users down an
additional benefit that we have with
these Banner shards I've talked about is
we can perform slow rollouts which
allows us to observe how changes perform
incrementally and that's a huge win for
our reliability of the Google photos
product
that's great because uh with spanner
you're literally using just one database
and that's just driving all of these
experiences whether it's batch upload or
it's uh it's these machine learning and
really rich features that we enjoy
um and experience now as we as we talk
about machine learning I have to ask can
we dive a little bit into how some of
those ml features work especially at
that scale of photos for I'll take an
example here if I wanted to search my
library for something like let's say I
love my dog let's say I'm searching for
all the pictures of my dog I'm wanting
to create a custom album how does that
work
scale has become a bigger and bigger
challenge as we've grown as a product we
rely really heavily on asynchronous
background processing to handle that
scale and it actually makes up the
majority of our workloads these days so
after a photo gets uploaded to the
system we cue that photo up for various
forms of offline image processing and ml
inference that help us label understand
and organize that media within a user's
Library the system doesn't just try to
infer the semantic contents of a single
photo but it actually tries to
understand how that content fits into
the broader context of a user's library
and doing so involves many large and
complicated queries within a user's
Library all of which kind of happen
concurrently with many other reason
rights running at the same time
and once the system's inferred labels
from that photo the labels actually get
stored in spanner indexed by our
Downstream indexing system they get
combined with outputs from our
clustering algorithm and form a basis on
which users can search their library and
experience it in different ways this
reminds me of an example where I um so
at my wedding I had some extensions on
so I had long hair and
um and and I normally I never had that
before so
um it got like so when I when I uploaded
those pictures got uploaded there's like
there was this confirmation right is
this still you and then it's like taking
four or five of these examples and like
trying to evaluate if it's still me
um which was amazing like I would like I
love those features where I don't have
to tell you that it's me you're like I
already identifying it's me and then
doing it and it's all that machine
learning goodness that's happening so
with that uh photos search really is an
amazing feature but also sounds like a
lot of a lot went into building it right
yeah to your point the system is
constantly learning and improving and we
really want to deliver the best possible
user experience that we can we push
ourselves constantly on it but to tell
you the truth we're so lucky to have a
large and really talented team working
on Google photos and we're also
supported by a great research team and a
whole bunch of great infrastructure
teams it really is one big team effort
to make all of this happen
and now I keep going back to that life
of a photo because I really grasp
concepts with some examples so here's
another scenario I love the pictures
from my recent trip to Costa Rica and I
really want to share them let's say with
my mom who is across the world in India
how does sharing like that in real world
happens how does that work
yeah so we're a close tie sharing
product and we really want to make sure
that no matter how far your friends and
family are you're able to share your
memories with them and you know even if
it is a global user base users still
have high standards they want seamless
real-time sharing of their content
unfortunately spanner has Global indices
and other functionality which have
helped us deliver on that user
experience
and if you think about it this this
really is conceptually very simple you
have users that are floating their photo
bytes are going into blob storage the
metadata is going into spanner and there
are lots of microservices all that are
receiving and adding information to this
Central huge scale database spinner but
the big deal here is the choice of tools
right so in this case spanner so can we
go into how spanner supports photos as
at such an incredible scale
simple is definitely good but the truth
is that we actually run hundreds of
binaries and microservices under the
hood and all of these Services have
different access patterns ranging from
small lookups to large data scans as
well as a variety of latency and
reliability requirements but despite all
that spanner's been able to meet every
requirement we've had completely off the
shelf it's been super flexible really
easy to use and I think it's really
impressive given our massive scale
so one of the key things as a user of
Google photos that I care about is the
security of my photos and videos who can
access them and when and how so how do
you handle the security aspect in Google
photos
user trust is a key part of our story
spanner is super reliable so we're
confident that user data will always be
available when a user wants it or needs
it and it's also super secure data is
encrypted at rest and it's tightly
Access Control to protect against Bad
actors or other unauthorized access
these are very fundamental security
measures that we have in place for every
feature and as we build new features
that security and privacy is kept in
mind from the very start which has
helped us iterate quickly without
compromising the bar
that is great to hear and as a user when
I have these pressure memories in my
photos I want to be able to trust that
I'll be able to access them reliably
wherever and whenever I want so um can
you tell a little bit about how spanner
assists with not just security but also
that trust powered
I think there's two key things I think
we have a simpler more maintainable
architecture and I think it's helped us
move more quickly and a lot of that is
because spanner is so scalable and easy
to use we have been able to sustain that
single database and it's yielded that
simpler development experience and
allowed us to lean into our micro system
architecture all of us in turn has
helped us manage our technical debt and
support a fast tight release cycle not
to mention spanners SQL features have
helped our developers write highly
optimized queries and also more easily
debug the features and services that
they're building
yeah Dave I was just remembering how
there was a lot of doubt in a lot of
people's mind that we could actually run
a database at this scale a single
database at this scale and it's we've
actually been very successful at it but
I would say equally as important for
velocity on the SRE side the fact that
spanner is reliable allows us to run a
single database and the features within
spanner we've significantly reduced our
toil as an SRE team we save a lot of
time and energy on tactical placements
location distribution sharding scaling
redundancy and the backup management for
replicas for example all we need to do
is input the specs to spanner and
spanner handles the change in the
replication that we would that we desire
in addition the self-healing nature of
spanners such as automated index
verifications automatic sharding
draining guaranteed data consistency
saves us a lot of manual work
anything else that you would like to
highlight that we haven't covered yet
look the truth is the photos have seen
amazing success running on spanner and I
think the numbers speak for themselves
our product is massive over a billion
users over a trillion images over 4
trillion images all stored securely and
privately and spanners played a huge
role in all of this it serves millions
of queries across dozens of geographical
zones in order to support us and believe
it or not we've actually experienced
that 10x growth since starting out and
we're confident that spanner is going to
be able to support another 10-fold
increase and continue to help us develop
to deliver amazing incredible user
experiences it's really amazing what
it's helped us to do and I can't wait to
see what helps us do in the future quite
frankly I think it's going to really
help us bring Google photos to the next
billion users
that is amazing thank you so much for
sharing your insights with me walking me
through how the whole thing works what
happens with the photo and what is
happening behind the scenes empowering
that amazing experience that billions of
us are using today
um thank you Dave and Tracy
hey Priyanka thanks for having us we
love to talk about photos all day long
as you can tell
yeah this was a ton of fun thanks so
much Priyanka well I really learned a
lot about the lifo photo and how it goes
through the Google photos infrastructure
the big lesson as a cloud architect here
is the architecture is usually pretty
simple it's the choice of the right
tools that lead to success in Meeting
those goals in this case spanner is the
key ingredient in scaling the photos
platform
thank you